Hey guys, what's up? Hi. Hi. Oh my gosh. It's a new show. It's a new... Oh, this is an opening for... Oh, we have a guest waiting?
嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？嗨。嗨。天哪。这是一个新节目。这是一个新的……哦，这是开场……哦，我们有位嘉宾在等候吗？
Yeah, we've got a guest. We're going to do the whole thing. And people are settling in. They're starting their jog. They're starting their drive. They're getting into the hot tub down in Australia. Yeah, I know you. Get some finger sandwiches.
是的，我们有一位嘉宾。我们要全程进行。人们正在安顿下来。他们开始慢跑了。他们开始开车了。他们在澳大利亚的按摩浴缸里泡着。是的，我认识你。拿点手指三明治。
You think more people listen to us in the car or while they're exercising? That is a great question. We should do a poll. Yeah. Yeah. I wonder, when I'm exercising, I got to be watching TV. Hang on one second, Jason. This is an all-new smartlass.
你觉得更多人是在车里听我们的节目，还是在锻炼的时候听？这是一个很好的问题。我们应该做个民意调查。是的。是的。我很好奇，我锻炼的时候必须看电视。等一下，杰森。这是一个全新的Smartless。
Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart.
Smart。Smart。Smart。Smart。Smart。Smart。Smart。Smart。
Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Great.
Smart。Smart。Smart。Smart。Smart。Smart。Smart。太棒了。
Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart.
Smart。Smart。Smart。Smart。Smart。Smart。Smart。Smart。
Smart. Did a doctor friend of mine say that, like don't look at the laptop when you're in bed or the phone because it's supposed to keep you up or it doesn't, it makes me fall asleep? We'll see, but Rob just told me that it drains you. So does it just make you tired? Does it keep you up?
Smart。我有个医生朋友说过，睡觉时不要看笔记本电脑或手机，因为那会让你保持清醒，还是说不会，它反而让我睡着了？我们走着瞧，但罗布刚告诉我那会消耗你的精力。所以它只是让你累吗？它会让你睡不着吗？
Does it destroy your eyes? I should not look at a screen like at least 30 minutes before you go to bed. It affects your sleep because it has to do with brain activity, although you guys should be okay. You're not seeing yourself up for an online porn joke here, will you? We're not gonna see a lot of brain activity.
它会毁了你的眼睛吗？你应该在睡觉前至少30分钟不要看屏幕。它会影响你的睡眠，因为它与大脑活动有关，尽管你们应该没问题。你们不是在为在线色情笑话做铺垫吧？我们不会看到太多大脑活动的。
If we haven't seen any yet, it's not like we're gonna all of a sudden see a surge. You know what I mean? Well, maybe I had too much blue light when I was a kid. That could be it. Maybe that's a problem. Something. What time do you guys go to bed?
如果我们还没看到任何活动，也不像是我们突然会看到激增。你懂我的意思吗？好吧，也许我小时候接触了太多的蓝光。可能是那样。也许那是个问题。什么东西。你们几点睡觉？
I need better sleep hygiene. I need to start going to bed at the same time. Your sleep hygiene is disgusting. But what does that mean? What, you sleep dirty? What do you- No, sleep hygiene is just making sure you sleep better. Like if a better-
我需要更好的睡眠卫生。我需要开始在同一时间睡觉。你的睡眠卫生真恶心。但那是什么意思？什么，你睡得很脏？你到底……不，睡眠卫生只是确保你睡得更好。就像如果一个更好的……
Your sleep routine. It's called sleep hygiene. What do you guys sleep in? You guys sleep in... Sean, you sleep in pajamas and one of those kind of like cone pajama hats with a little tassel at the end. With the feties?
你的睡眠习惯。这叫睡眠卫生。你们穿什么睡觉？你们穿……肖恩，你穿睡衣和那种末端带流苏的圆锥形睡帽吗？带脚套的吗？
Like the night before Christmas. With a candle. I carry my candle to bed. With a hand in front of it, so the wind doesn't blow down. Sean looks like a TV, he looks like a TV husband from the 90s in like pajama bottoms in a nondescript T-shirt.
就像《圣诞前夜》里那样。带着蜡烛。我带着蜡烛上床。用手挡在前面，这样风就不会吹灭它。肖恩看起来像个电视，他看起来像90年代电视里的丈夫，穿着睡裤和一件普通的T恤。
Sure. Right? Yeah. Kids, let's shut those lights out. We're half hour past your bedtime. No, you're supposed to, by the way, this is what I read. Between 10 p.m. and 2 a.m.
当然。对吧？是的。孩子们，把灯关掉。已经过了你们睡觉时间半小时了。不，顺便说一下，你应该这样做，这是我读到的。晚上10点到凌晨2点。
is when the best sleep is supposed to happen. I don't know how your body knows the hour time, but that's what I heard. This sounds like a weird website. Well, you know, according to Folger's, the best part of waking up, yeah. The best... Hey, no, for real though, what time do you go to bed?
是据说睡眠质量最好的时候。我不知道你的身体怎么知道时间，但我听说的是这样。这听起来像个奇怪的网站。好吧，你知道，根据Folger's咖啡的说法，醒来最好的部分，是的。最好的……嘿，不，说真的，你几点睡觉？
I want to get to our guests because we have an incredible guest who's being very patient, but what time do you get to... Jason, what time do you go to bed? I go to bed at a probably, no later than 10 30. And that's when it's really gotten away from me. Sean.
我想请出我们的嘉宾，因为我们有一位非常棒的嘉宾，她非常有耐心，但你几点……杰森，你几点睡觉？我大概不晚于10点半睡觉。那是真的忙不过来的时候。肖恩。
Wait, listen, just because you said that, when I did the Kenny Rogers Christmas tour, and he sang... No, I have all the time in the world for this. Make this a long one. And Kenny used to sing, Christmas in America, the sweetest time of year, right? We'd be backstage and he would go,
等等，听着，就因为你说了那个，当我做肯尼·罗杰斯圣诞巡演时，他唱……不，我有的是时间听这个。把它说长点。肯尼过去常唱，《美国圣诞节》，一年中最甜蜜的时光，对吧？我们在后台，他会说，
Christmas in America, and we would go, is Folger's in your cup? He was right though, Kenny was right. Here it comes. Ireland's in the stream, that is what we are. You know who wrote that song? Dolly Parton. Nope, the Bee Gees.
《美国圣诞节》，我们会说，你的杯子里有Folger's咖啡吗？不过他是对的，肯尼是对的。来了。溪流中的岛屿，这就是我们。你知道谁写的那首歌吗？多莉·帕顿。不，比吉斯乐队。
Jennifer Warren, the Bee Gees. Yeah. I'm glad we've got some extra openers. So, I realized that I would describe our guest as an island in the stream. This person is a true Eddie. Brooke Shields of Cheddar Rivera. No.
詹妮弗·沃伦，比吉斯乐队。是的。我很高兴我们有一些额外的开场白。所以我意识到我会把我们的嘉宾描述为溪流中的岛屿。这个人是一个真正的埃迪。布鲁克·雪德丝还是切达·里维拉。不。
Chris Hatkins. No, sorry, are we not guessing? Well, it was not just the cast of the Blue Lagoon, man. So, our guest is a multi-hyphenate, just a multi-talented person who I first became aware of in a film from the early 2000s that was very popular at the time that was directed by a guy called David Wayne.
克里斯·哈特金斯。不，抱歉，我们不是在猜吗？好吧，不仅仅是《蓝色珊瑚礁》的演员，伙计。所以，我们的嘉宾是一位多才多艺的人，我第一次注意到她是在2000年代初的一部电影中，当时非常受欢迎，由一个叫大卫·韦恩的人执导。
It was a movie called Wet Hot American Summer. She then went on to play in a million movies, some of the biggest hits, but then became an incredible director. I got to know her during the Lego movies, really got to know her, and then she went on to start directing, and she directed what is now the biggest gross opening
那是一部叫《哈拉夏令营》的电影。她后来出演了数百万部电影，其中一些是最大的热门，但后来成为了一名出色的导演。我在《乐高大电影》期间认识了她，真正了解了她，然后她开始执导，她执导了现在首位导演处女作中票房最高的电影
ever for a first-time director with Pitch Perfect 2. Aw, Chris has a big face. It's a little bit of a big face, everybody. Woo-hoo. There she is. Oh my gosh. Not a lot of people know this, but you are the wife of David Cross.
《完美音调2》。噢，克里斯有一张大脸。大家，这脸有点大。呜呼。她在那儿。天哪。没多少人知道这一点，但你是大卫·克罗斯的妻子。
We just learned on our episode with David. Did you guys remember that? I was just listening to David Cross' episode. He said that his wife, I think Sean, you asked him who he's married to, and he said a little bit of things. A little bit of things. Yes, that's true.
我们刚在大卫的那一集里了解到。你们记得吗？我刚才在听大卫·克罗斯的那一集。他说他的妻子，我想肖恩，你问他娶了谁，他说了一些事情。一些事情。是的，那是真的。
Actually, David Cross and I are husband and wife. It's not legal. It's not a legal thing. Oh, it's not legal. No. Look at the lizard. Haven't seen you for a long time. You guys, I'm sorry.
其实，大卫·克罗斯和我确实是夫妻。这不是合法的。这不是法律上的事情。哦，不是合法的。不。看看那只蜥蜴。好久没见你了。你们，我很抱歉。
I'm such a disappointment after you're hoping Brooke Shields shows up. Well, listen, it's just me, guys. We have love for everybody. We have love for everybody. I'm so happy you're here. You're one of those people. I always feel like when I see you, you make me smile.
在你们希望布鲁克·雪德丝出现之后，我真是个令人失望的人。好吧，听着，只有我，伙计们。我们爱每一个人。我们爱每一个人。我很高兴你在这里。你是那种人。我总觉得当我看到你时，你让我微笑。
I'm always happy to see you. Aw. You're always- It's true. It's true. And you're also one of those rare finds in Hollywood, a girl who's absolutely unbelievably hilarious and unbelievably gorgeous at the same time.
我总是很高兴见到你。噢。你总是……这是真的。这是真的。而且你也是好莱坞罕见的发现，一个绝对令人难以置信的搞笑，同时又令人难以置信美丽的女孩。
I love that you call me a girl, Sean, is the greatest compliment that you could be paying me. And listen, this is the first time I think anybody's ever worn something halfway decent to do, I mean, she's got a very nice blouse on. She's combed her hair. This was not for you guys.
肖恩，我喜欢你叫我女孩，这是你能给我的最高赞美。而且听着，我想这是第一次有人穿得像样点来做节目，我是说，她穿了一件非常漂亮的衬衫。她梳了头发。这不是为了你们。
I'm gonna be totally honest. I had to do another thing before this. I wish I was in my pajamas. Like these? My footed pajamas. What was the thing? Can you say? I was doing a panel with Stacey Snyder,
我要说实话。在这之前我还有别的事。我真希望我穿着睡衣。像这些？我的连脚睡衣。是什么事？能说吗？我正在和斯泰西·斯奈德参加一个小组讨论，
who's another big wig in our business. Sure, huh? Sure. For, we both went to the same university and we did a panel for an alumni thing. For Penn, you went to university of Pennsylvania. I? Will, aren't I?
她是我们要在这个行业里的另一个大人物。当然，哈？当然。我们俩都去了同一所大学，我们为一个校友活动做了一个小组讨论。为了宾大，你去了宾夕法尼亚大学。我？威尔，我不是吗？
I went to the school. I did, I went to Penn. Yes, I went to Penn in Philadelphia. And so did Stacey Snyder. And so did a bunch of Hollywood types. And Stacey and I. I think you graduated with honors, did you not? I did.
我去了那所学校。我去了，我去了宾大。是的，我在费城去了宾大。斯泰西·斯奈德也是。还有一堆好莱坞类型的人。斯泰西和我。我想你是以优异成绩毕业的，不是吗？是的。
Oh, who's done some research? Will found the Wikipedia page on those banks. Come on, tell us. Will's on the wiki. No, I don't wiki, I don't wiki. Uh-huh. Magna glada, maybe? That's true.
噢，谁做了一些研究？威尔在维基百科上找到了那些银行。来吧，告诉我们。威尔在维基上。不，我不维基，我不维基。嗯哼。优等生，也许？那是真的。
Those are some Latin words that are on my degree. Yes, they are. Was your, was your degree in theater or? It was in communications and also theater arts. But yeah, the school, they're not a big theater arts program at Penn. Can I ask you a question here? Cause I did not go to college.
那些是我学位上的一些拉丁词。是的，它们是。你的学位是戏剧还是？是传播学，还有戏剧艺术。但是是的，学校，宾大的戏剧艺术项目不是很大。我能问你一个问题吗？因为我没上过大学。
This is going to be great. And this is going to come as a surprise to a lot of people. But I did not go. This is going to be a great, by the way, I don't have a degree or, yeah. Here it is. This is this, a good dumb question from a good dumb guy.
这会很棒。这对很多人来说会是个惊喜。但我没去。顺便说一下，这会很棒，我没有学位，或者，是的。在这儿。这是一个来自好笨蛋的好笨问题。
How hard is college? And I mean it. What an episode. Thanks for joining us. I do, I do mean it. And now from what I understand. I buy it with you, Jason. This is not a bit.
大学有多难？我是认真的。多棒的一集。谢谢你加入我们。我，我是认真的。现在据我所知。我和你一起买账，杰森。这不是个段子。
This is not a bit, okay? First of all, I didn't even graduate high school. I dropped out of college. It should be noted. But it's my understanding that there are two years of general ed, right? Which is sort of the college level history. College level English, college level math.
这不是个段子，好吗？首先，我甚至没从高中毕业。我从大学退学了。应该指出的是。但据我了解，有两年的通识教育，对吧？也就是大学水平的历史。大学水平的英语，大学水平的数学。
That's for two years. Which sounds like a nightmare, okay? And then the last two years, this is my understanding, is that you get to study your minor and your major. So, you know, I want to become a roofer or I want to become, you know what? Whatever the hell it is. I'm just saying, you can pick whatever occupation you want
那是两年。听起来像场噩梦，好吗？然后最后两年，这是我的理解，你可以学习你的辅修和主修。所以，你知道，我想成为一名屋顶工或者我想成为，你知道吗？不管那是什么鬼东西。我只是说，你可以选择任何你想要的职业
and study your nards off about it. And there's no, so that sounds fun. But those first two years sound really difficult. Is that the way it goes? Not really. I mean, what? How do you answer that question? It's no don't.
然后拼命学习它。而且没有，所以听起来很有趣。但前两年听起来真的很困难。是这样吗？不完全是。我是说，什么？你怎么回答那个问题？不是不。
It's no don't. No, but let me say something. Were you gonna sleep right before this? Yeah. No, let me say something. It's high school harder. I'm kind of with, I'm kind of with Jason because, you know, this long kind of idea about
不是不。不，但让我说点什么。高中更难吗？我有点，我有点同意杰森，因为，你知道，这个关于
is college necessary, you know? Does anybody really need to go to college? Additional voluntary school. It doesn't make any sense to me. I learned, here's what I learned guys. I learned about what kind of alcohol I liked. I learned about drug use. Yeah.
大学是否有必要，你知道？真的有人需要上大学吗？额外的自愿学校。这对我来说毫无意义。我学到了，这是我学到的，伙计们。我学到了我喜欢什么样的酒精。我学到了关于药物使用。是的。
I learned how to get into a club in Philly, which was, and I learned about, I went to my first jazz club, which was amazing. It's like underground jazz club in Philadelphia. That's the stuff that mattered. That's why, you know, I met my husband. Sweet, sweet Max. Well, that's good.
我学到了如何在费城进入一家俱乐部，那是，我学到了关于，我去了我的第一个爵士俱乐部，那太棒了。就像费城的地下爵士俱乐部。那才是重要的东西。这就是为什么，你知道，我遇到了我的丈夫。甜甜的马克斯。好吧，那很好。
That's good. I liked college because I mean. But with the arts, I have a scholarship set up at the Illinois State University where I went for theater. Oh, Jesus, hang on a second. College graduate, Sean Hayes. Thank you.
那很好。我喜欢大学，因为我是说。但对于艺术，我在我上戏剧课的伊利诺伊州立大学设立了奖学金。噢，耶稣，等一下。大学毕业生，肖恩·海耶斯。谢谢。
Well, I didn't. I got an honorary doctorate, but I never graduated. But I think it's important for the arts because it's where everybody gathers for the first time to really kind of become vulnerable and learn from each other and grow and figure out where your place is in the field of theater and arts.
好吧，我没有。我拿到了荣誉博士学位，但我从未毕业。但我认为这对艺术很重要，因为这是每个人第一次聚集在一起，真正变得脆弱，互相学习，成长，并找出你在戏剧和艺术领域的位置。
It's a lot of that too. This is where I'm coming from. Like you can't really, you can't fail in college, right? Like it's only, you can learn as much as you apply yourself to learn. That's right. There's no obligation to score a certain number on a certain number of tests like high school.
那也有很多。这就是我的出发点。就像你不能在大学里失败，对吧？就像只有，你可以学习你投入学习的那么多。那是对的。没有义务在某些测试中获得一定的分数，像高中那样。
No, it's all self-imposed. That's the greatest part about it, right? Sounds great. So everything is self-imposed. I think that's maybe everything in life. I mean, other than like you have to pay some bills. So you have to make some money to pay bills, but like really so much of this pressure
不，一切都是自我强加的。那是关于它最棒的部分，对吧？听起来不错。所以一切都是自我强加的。我想那也许是生活中的一切。我是说，除了你必须支付一些账单。所以你必须赚些钱来支付账单，但真的，这么多压力
on ourselves is all self-imposed. Where did you grow up? I grew up in Western Massachusetts in Pittsfield, Massachusetts. Okay. In short, Massachusetts. By the way, how many people from your high school went to Penn?
在我们自己身上都是自我强加的。你在哪里长大的？我在马萨诸塞州西部的皮茨菲尔德长大。好的。简而言之，马萨诸塞州。顺便问一下，你们高中里有多少人去了宾大？
Just me, Matt. I don't know, maybe a couple other people eventually went there. Sure. Somebody's a real overtuber. Matt, I went to public high school guys, like in a small town where we literally went into the fields and tipped cows
只有我，马特。我不知道，也许还有几个人最终去了那里。当然。有人是个真正的过度成就者。马特，我上了公立高中，伙计们，在一个小镇上，我们真的去田野里推牛，
when we drank too many beers. Are you gonna want your kids to be academics like you? Or are you gonna say, yeah, no, it's not that big a deal. You just learned how to get into clubs and go to like jazz functions. Well, I mean, I did learn some cool things too. I mean, I've never studied certain, and I picked up a love for learning things.
当我们喝了太多啤酒的时候。你会希望你的孩子像你一样成为学者吗？还是你会说，是的，不，那没什么大不了的。你只是学会了如何进入俱乐部和去参加像爵士乐活动。好吧，我是说，我也学到了一些很酷的东西。我是说，我从未学习过某些东西，我培养了对学习事物的热爱。
And I had access, I really felt lucky to have the access I had to the amazing professors that I got to learn from. And some of them were total assholes. I remember this one professor who was like, just laid things that like I needed to miss a class for a family thing and I love my family. And she was like, too bad, you're in college now,
而且我有机会，我真的觉得很幸运能有我所拥有的机会，向我得以学习的那些了不起的教授学习。其中一些是彻头彻尾的混蛋。我记得有一位教授，就像，只是设定了一些我因为家庭原因需要缺课的事情，我爱我的家人。她说，太糟糕了，你现在上大学了，
like you're over 18 and you don't get to, you either this or that. And I remember having to make that kind of decision for the first time. She was right. I chose my family. She was right. And she ticked, nicked my grade. And it was like, wow, okay, this, I'm an adult.
就像你超过18岁了，你不能，你要么这样要么那样。我记得第一次不得不做出那种决定。她是正确的。我选择了我的家人。她是正确的。她扣了我的分数。就像，哇，好吧，这，我是个成年人。
I gotta say, and I think the world of you, but I'm on her side. You made a bad decision. Because I think we live in a world where there's too much of that, like especially in our business, of like, I gotta go, I gotta go visit, like too fucking bad.
我必须说，我非常看重你，但我站在她那边。你做了一个错误的决定。因为我认为我们生活在一个充满那种东西的世界里，特别是在我们的行业里，就像，我得走，我得去拜访，去他妈的糟糕。
Too bad. No, you don't get a special dispensation because you like have a loving family. That's off. Did you go back to, to Massachusetts when after college or did you go straight to LA? I did not go straight to LA. I did more fucking school.
太糟糕了。不，你不会因为你有一个充满爱的家庭而得到特殊豁免。那是不对的。大学毕业后你回到了马萨诸塞州，还是直接去了洛杉矶？我没有直接去洛杉矶。我做了更多该死的学校。
She went down to B.F.A. I could get more school. M.F.A. I got a master's degree. M.F.A. Sorry, sorry. Oh, oh, oh, sorry. You got a master's? I got a B.A. and I have an M.F.A.
她去读了艺术硕士。我可以读更多学校。艺术硕士。抱歉，抱歉。噢，噢，噢，抱歉。你拿到了硕士学位？我拿到了文学学士，我有一个艺术硕士。
Yeah, I went to drama school. I went to drama school. And honestly, I went to drama school partially because I thought maybe I wanted to be an actor, but where I'm from, nobody is an artist. That's not a career. That's not something anybody does. Wow, that's not true.
是的，我去了戏剧学校。我去了戏剧学校。老实说，我去戏剧学校部分是因为我以为也许我想成为一名演员，但从我来的地方，没有人是艺术家。那不是职业。那不是任何人做的事情。哇，那不是真的。
Fucking some beer artists. We got some fucking beer artists. There's a lot of that. You're absolutely right. However, you, you, I remember, you just reminded me of something. I went to an event in Massachusetts not that long ago and this guy got up with our, with the Mass accent
他妈的一些啤酒艺术家。我们有一些他妈的啤酒艺术家。有很多那种。你是绝对正确的。然而，你，你，我记得，你刚才提醒了我一件事。不久前我去马萨诸塞州参加了一个活动，这个家伙带着我们的马萨诸塞口音站了起来，
and he was like, this is Elizabeth Banks. She, you know, in my high school, if you were a little different, maybe you went to the acts, you know? You did some acts, like the different kids did the acts. Yeah, sure, different. They did the acts. Anyway, so I was in the acts,
他说，这是伊丽莎白·班克斯。她，你知道，在我高中时，如果你有点不同，也许你参加了表演，你知道？你做了一些表演，就像不同的孩子做表演。是的，当然，不同。他们做了表演。总之，所以我参加了表演，
but that was not something you did where I'm from. But if you got a master's in drama school, does that mean that you thought, okay, I might be an actor, but if I am an actor, it's gonna be like a serious dramatic actor. Was comedy even on your radar? Comedy was on my radar,
但那不是我来的地方你会做的事情。但如果你拿到了戏剧学校的硕士学位，那是否意味着你认为，好吧，我可能是一名演员，但如果我是演员，那会像一个严肃的戏剧演员。喜剧甚至在你的雷达上吗？喜剧在我的雷达上，
but the degree was because I didn't know how to go to New York City and get an act. I didn't understand what was step one. I'm not even kidding you. It was like, a lot of people don't know. So I show up and I get a job as a waitress and then what happens? Yeah, where do I go?
但学位是因为我不知道如何去纽约市并获得表演。我不明白第一步是什么。我甚至不是在开玩笑。就像，很多人不知道。所以我出现并找了一份服务员的工作，然后发生了什么？是的，我去哪儿？
Where, what, is there an office or a phone number that you call like a back stage? Yeah, like you go to the open calls and backstage. So what did you do? So how did you find out? Yeah, tell us how it worked. I didn't have to do any of that because I went to drama school
去哪儿，什么，有一个办公室或电话号码，你打电话像后台？是的，就像你去公开试镜和后台。那你做了什么？所以你是怎么发现的？是的，告诉我们它是怎么运作的。我不需要做任何那些，因为我去了戏剧学校，
and when you go to drama school, they do a showcase and you meet agents and then they call you and they go, do you want me to represent you? And I go, yes, please. And then you start acting like the next day and literally that is what happened. Wow.
当你去戏剧学校时，他们会做一个展示，你见到经纪人，然后他们打电话给你，他们说，你想让我代表你吗？我说，是的，请。然后你第二天就开始演戏，字面上就是那样发生的。哇。
So you went on auditions and you just started booking stuff. My very first day, so I did my showcase and the next morning, I got asked to audition for a soap. I think it was as the world turns. And then that afternoon, they called and said,
所以你去试镜，然后就开始预订东西。我的第一天，所以我做了我的展示，第二天早上，我被要求去试镜一部肥皂剧。我想是《地球照样转动》。然后那天下午，他们打电话说，
do you want to be on this soap opera for two years? And I had not even graduated, ACT yet. And so you did it? I did not do it. Oh, what? I didn't do it. What do you mean? She's listed up in banks, man,
你想在这部肥皂剧里演两年吗？我甚至还没从ACT毕业。所以你做了？我没做。噢，什么？我没做。你是什么意思？她是班克斯，伙计，
and in her first day, she gets a two-year gig and turns them down based on what? That was part of it. A few things. One, I wanted to finish school. They were like, come tomorrow, like you're on this show tomorrow. I now know as I've spent a long time in the business,
在她第一天，她得到了一份两年的工作，却拒绝了，基于什么？那是其中的一部分。几件事。第一，我想完成学业。他们就像，明天来，就像你明天就在这个节目里。我现在知道，因为我在这个行业待了很长时间，
I produce things, you make things, I cast a lot of things. And sometimes they're just looking for the person and if you walk in and solve it, you're literally hired and you show up the next day, right? And that just happens every once in a while. So that's what happened. They had been looking for somebody to play this role
我制作东西，你制作东西，我选角很多东西。有时他们只是在找那个人，如果你走进去解决了它，你字面上就被雇用了，你第二天就出现，对吧？而那只是偶尔发生。所以这就是发生的。他们一直在找人演这个角色，
for a couple of weeks and then I happened to walk in the door and they were like, it's gonna be you. And I said, actually, it's not gonna be me. And I remember I was on a pay phone because that's how old we all are. I was on a pay phone in New York City up by Lincoln Center. I called my mom, I had massive student loans, like major, and I called my mother and I said,
几个星期，然后我碰巧走进门，他们就像，会是你。我说，其实，不会是我。我记得我在一个公用电话上，因为我们都那么老了。我在纽约市林肯中心附近的公用电话上。我给我妈打电话，我有巨额学生贷款，就像主要的，我给我母亲打电话，我说，
they offered me this job and I turned it down. It was $250,000 for two years. This is more money that I'd ever seen in my entire life and it would have paid everything. And like, it was, yeah. And I said, I'm not gonna do it. And I burst into tears because I thought, I knew it was the right decision, but I also,
他们给了我这份工作，我拒绝了。那是两年25万美元。这是我一生中见过的最多的钱，它会支付一切。而且就像，它是，是的。我说，我不会做。我泪流满面，因为我想，我知道这是正确的决定，但我也，
I was really scared. I was really scared not to have money because I was eating like a bagel a day. But wait a minute, but I'm sorry, I may have missed it. Why, what was the main reason you turned it down? To stay in school? Just to... I wanted to finish school, one, but more than anything, I'm not kidding.
我真的很害怕。我真的很害怕没有钱，因为我每天吃一个百吉饼。但等一下，但我很抱歉，我可能错过了。为什么，你拒绝它的主要原因是什么？为了留在学校？只是……我想完成学业，第一，但最重要的是，我不是在开玩笑。
I thought to myself, if I can get a soap on day one, what can I get on day two? Awesome. Yeah, God damn, that's Western magic. I'm not even kidding. That is some hardcore shit. Yeah, fucking eight. I was fucking hardcore. And then how long was it before your next offer?
我心想，如果我第一天就能得到一部肥皂剧，第二天我能得到什么？太棒了。是的，该死，那是马萨诸塞的魔法。我甚至不是在开玩笑。那是些硬核的东西。是的，他妈的八。我他妈的硬核。然后距离你的下一个报价有多久？
I got it commercial like a week later. Wow. Oh, good. Yeah, so you just came home. And I signed with the one agent who said to me, like, no, no, no, don't take that job. Like, I think he, because I didn't know anything about the business either. So remember, I went to New York,
我一周后得到了一个广告。哇。噢，好。是的，所以你只是回家了。我签了那个对我说，不，不，不，不要接受那份工作的经纪人。就像，我想他，因为我当时对这个行业一无所知。所以记住，我去了纽约，
did a showcase from drama school thinking, I'm gonna be like a chorus girl on Broadway. Right, my dream. My dream, my dream was not to dream. No, Sean, Sean's dream. Oh yeah, Sean's dream. Sean's dream, Sean's dream. I wanted Sean's dream too.
从戏剧学校做了一个展示，心想，我要成为百老汇的合唱女孩。对，我的梦想。我的梦想，我的梦想不是梦想。不，肖恩，肖恩的梦想。噢是的，肖恩的梦想。肖恩的梦想，肖恩的梦想。我也想要肖恩的梦想。
And so when I got offered a soap opera, which was not my dream, but it was just like an amazing money job and a foray into New York and all that. But it wasn't my dream. And I thought, oh wait, I don't think that's what I want to do. And at the time, everybody was doing,
所以当我被提供一部肥皂剧时，那不是我的梦想，但它就像一份惊人的金钱工作和进入纽约的尝试，所有这些。但那不是我的梦想。我想，噢等等，我不认为那是我想做的事情。当时，每个人都在做，
remember like Scream was like the big movie. I remember Party of Five was on it. The Neve Campbell was like my dream. Sure. And I remember thinking, I don't need to do this soap opera. Like I actually do want to keep pursuing the things that I want to do.
记得像《惊声尖叫》是那种大电影。我记得《五口之家》在播。内芙·坎贝尔就像我的梦想。当然。我记得心想，我不需要做这部肥皂剧。就像我确实想继续追求我想做的事情。
And maybe I'll be on Broadway and maybe, and then the commercial world was also something I knew nothing about. You could make a lot of money in commercials in those days. And I did. I paid off all my student loans with the commercial work. No way. Will Arnett would have been fine too.
也许我会上百老汇，也许，然后广告世界也是我一无所知的东西。在那些日子里，你可以在广告中赚很多钱。我做了。我用广告工作还清了所有的学生贷款。没门。威尔·阿内特也会没事的。
Because how many goddamn commercials do you record in that booth of yours right there? A lot. A lot. Well, I graduated from no more drama school. You know what I'm talking about? How you doing? How you doing?
因为你在那个展位里录了多少该死的广告？很多。很多。好吧，我从不再戏剧学校毕业了。你知道我在说什么吗？你好吗？你好吗？
I'm doing fine. And now back to the show. What were those first couple of years in New York like being a waitress and going from audition to audition and trying to have a social life too? Did the city, was that easy for you? I loved every second of it. I did not sleep.
我很好。现在回到节目。在纽约做服务员，从试镜到试镜，还要尝试有社交生活，那最初的几年是什么样的？城市，那对你来说容易吗？我爱它的每一秒。我没睡觉。
So my first summer after drama school, I went and moved to New York. And I was a waitress at Prohibition on 84th and Columbus on the west side. And I did some bartending there as well. And I worked with this woman named Bonnie. Bonnie was, she was studying to be a flight attendant. She was like an ex model.
所以我戏剧学校后的第一个夏天，我搬到了纽约。我在西区84街和哥伦布大道的Prohibition做服务员。我也在那里做了一些调酒。我和一个叫邦妮的女人一起工作。邦妮是，她正在学习成为一名空姐。她就像一个前模特。
She lives over in the ocean. How do you study? You have to go to like the school, like the Delta school in Texas and learn how to be a flight attendant. So Bonnie had a bunch of animals. I never understood anyone who had a pet in New York City but whatever.
她住在海洋那边。你怎么学习？你必须去像德克萨斯州的达美学校，学习如何成为一名空姐。所以邦妮有一堆动物。我从未理解任何在纽约市有宠物的人，但不管怎样。
So she had a bunch of animals. She had like a dog and a cat and a bird or something. And she started going away and she had a boyfriend that she was staying at. And so she said, you can move into and live in my studio apartment with these three animals and watch my animals. And we'll, we'll, when she is back.
所以她有一堆动物。她有一只狗和一只猫和一只鸟什么的。她开始离开，她有一个她住在一起的男朋友。所以她说，你可以搬进并住在我的单间公寓里，带着这三只动物，看管我的动物。我们会，我们会，当她回来时。
So there's a bed and a couch. And if she was in town, she got the bed and I got the couch. But if she was flying, like doing her overnight, then I got the bed. And then after a while we just were like, let's just go sleep in the bed. And so the main thing that people like to hear about my time-
所以有一张床和一张沙发。如果她在城里，她睡床，我睡沙发。但如果她在飞行，就像做她的过夜，那么我睡床。然后过了一会儿我们只是觉得，让我们去床上睡吧。所以人们喜欢听到的关于我时间的主要是——
Let's just film it. How long is it before let's just film it? When did that happen? Is that? Sorry. I was literally sleeping in a bed with Bonnie, the bartender slash flight attendant X model and her dog. And we would just sleep in a bed together
让我们拍下来。距离让我们拍下来有多久？那是什么时候发生的？是吗？抱歉。我真的和邦妮，那个调酒师兼空姐前模特和她的狗睡在一张床上。我们只是睡在一张床上，
on 101st and Columbus. And that was my life for like six months. And then I, my now husband moved back to New York and we moved in together. Anyway, so those are my days. I lived with a flight attendant. I was a bartender and a waitress. I went on my auditions.
在101街和哥伦布大道。那是我大约六个月的生活。然后我，我现在的丈夫搬回了纽约，我们住在一起。总之，这就是我的日子。我和一个空姐住在一起。我是一个调酒师和服务员。我去试镜。
I had a roller bag that I would carry around because, you know, and by the way, I walked around in heels back then. This was like sex in the city time. So you felt like not, you weren't a real woman if you couldn't walk near city streets and high heels. So I walked around in high heels and I had all my changes, all my clothes, my changes for my auditions.
我有一个滚轮包，我会随身携带，因为，你知道，顺便说一下，我那时穿着高跟鞋走来走去。这就像《欲望都市》时代。所以你觉得，如果你不能穿着高跟鞋在城市街道上行走，你就不是一个真正的女人。所以我穿着高跟鞋走来走去，我有我所有的换装，我所有的衣服，我试镜的换装。
Cause I had auditioned for a doctor and then I auditioned for a lawyer. And then I had to plan for- And your head shot, your head shot was in four quadrants. They may have had each one of those. This is like, this is like what? Like 97, 98, 99, all in there. Exactly, exactly.
因为我试镜了一个医生，然后我试镜了一个律师。然后我必须计划——还有你的头像，你的头像在四个象限里。他们可能每个都有一个。这就像，这就像什么？就像97，98，99，都在那里。完全，完全。
Did you ever see me like rollerblading by? Did you ever see me rollerblading? Oh my God, I totally rollerbladed. I went to the Central Park and like, did the rollerblading thing. Oh, me too. I played hockey and I would rollerblade uptown and then I go by and then I, if I'd see some, you know,
你有没有见过我像轮滑一样经过？你有没有见过我轮滑？噢天哪，我完全轮滑了。我去了中央公园，就像，做了轮滑的事情。噢，我也是。我打曲棍球，我会轮滑到上城，然后我经过，然后我，如果我看到一些，你知道，
a girl on a street corner that kind of slowed down, like she is paying attention to the guy on the rollerblades. So what do you do? Well, hang on a sec. Well, let me paint this picture here. So you got a hard look there. Like there's a lot of bunch of smoke in the room, right? So the eyes are real tight.
街角的女孩有点慢下来，就像她在注意轮滑的家伙。那你做什么？好吧，等一下。好吧，让我描绘一下这幅图景。所以你那里有一个硬朗的表情。就像房间里有很多烟，对吧？所以眼睛真的很紧。
And then what you're dragging one of your skates behind you to slow down a little bit. Smoking a butt. Smoking a butt. And then doing that thing where I look out and I just go and just answering to a question that was not asked and I just go, probably. Oh God.
然后你拖着你的一只溜冰鞋在后面慢下来一点。抽根烟。抽根烟。然后做那个我向外看，我只是去，只是回答一个没有被问到的问题，我只是去，大概。噢上帝。
And so would you have a plastic hockey stick sticking out of your backpack too? Just a hatch, right? Let's get back to Elizabeth. So, hey Elizabeth. So you're doing a ton of commercial stuff. You're doing, I mean, you're killing it in the commercial world.
那你背包里也会插着一根塑料曲棍球棒吗？只是一个舱口，对吧？让我们回到伊丽莎白。所以，嘿伊丽莎白。所以你做了很多广告的东西。你做了，我是说，你在广告世界里杀死了它。
You pay off your, I was gonna say, so you pay off your student loans. Yeah. Best feeling in the world. I paid off a student loan with like one Crest Whitestrips commercial. Wow. Back in the day.
你还清了你的，我正要说，所以你还清了你的学生贷款。是的。世界上最好的感觉。我用一个Crest美白贴纸广告还清了学生贷款。哇。在过去的日子里。
These big honking teeth. I have chicklets for teeth. They're ginormous. And I used to really dislike my teeth and now that, but they pay off a lot of student loans. Grass is always green. They're very all-American these teeth. They fell a lot of things.
这些巨大的牙齿。我有像小鸡一样的牙齿。它们巨大。我过去真的很不喜欢我的牙齿，现在，但它们还清了很多学生贷款。草总是绿的。这些牙齿非常美国化。它们掉了很多东西。
Jason did a Crest one too, the before shot, right? Didn't you do? Well, I was gonna, yeah, go ahead. Well, I was just, I mean, I was gonna flash all the way forward to like what the view is like on the top of the mountain. I mean, you're blazing, I mean, honestly, you are blazing trails for your peers.
杰森也做了一个Crest的，之前的镜头，对吧？你没做吗？好吧，我正要，是的，继续。好吧，我只是，我是说，我正要闪到像山顶上的景色是什么样的。我是说，你正在燃烧，我是说，老实说，你正在为你的同龄人开辟道路。
You're top of the world with acting, with directing, with producing, just smashing ceilings all over the place. I mean, do you have perspective on that? And I know it probably makes you uncomfortable to admit it or address it, but it really is, you know, super impressive what's going on. Very, yeah.
你在演戏，导演，制作方面处于世界顶端，到处都在打破天花板。我是说，你对此有视角吗？我知道这可能让你感到不舒服去承认或解决它，但这确实是，你知道，超级令人印象深刻。非常，是的。
Aw, thanks guys. No, I mean, yes, I, do I have perception on it? No, I really don't actually. I just, I don't know, I'm not kidding when I say, when you've committed to making Hollywood your place of employment. I mean, as you guys all know, what else are we supposed to do?
噢，谢谢你们。不，我是说，是的，我有对此的感知吗？不，我真的没有。我只是，我不知道，当我说，当你承诺让好莱坞成为你的就业地点时，我不是在开玩笑。我是说，正如你们都知道的，我们还能做什么？
You know what I mean? Right, it's frightening. You get to the point of no return. You're like, well, I have no other skills that I know no other people. I haven't done anything else. Like these are all the people I know. They create things and we put them out into the world.
你懂我的意思吗？对，这很可怕。你到了不归点。你就像，好吧，我没有其他技能，我不认识其他人。我没做过其他任何事。就像这些都是我认识的人。他们创造东西，我们把它们放到世界上。
And so I just thought, well, how else can I, how else can I take advantage of all these dim-dongs that I've met along the way? Right. What else can we do, you know? I'm one of those, I'm one of those guys who, shocker, I love Pitch Perfect, right? Thank you.
所以我只是想，好吧，我还能怎么，我还能怎么利用我一路上遇到的所有这些笨蛋？对。我们还能做什么，你知道？我是那种，我是那种家伙，震惊，我喜欢《完美音调》，对吧？谢谢。
And one of the greatest signs that your movie is a classic and stands the test of time is that when you see it and when you're scrolling through the guide, you have to flip it on and watch whatever, wherever it is in the movie and you just sit there and watch it and do that every single time.
而且你的电影是经典并经受住时间考验的最大标志之一是，当你看到它，当你滚动指南时，你必须打开它并观看任何东西，无论它在电影的哪里，你只是坐在那里看它，每次都这样做。
I see that movie and any sequel of it. And so, but what is the genesis of Pitch Perfect? How did it come about? How did you get involved? Like, what's the story of that from idea to script to screen? And then the second one too. Wow, thank you, Sean.
我看到那部电影和它的任何续集。所以，但《完美音调》的起源是什么？它是怎么来的？你是怎么参与进来的？就像，从想法到剧本到屏幕的故事是什么？然后第二个也是。哇，谢谢你，肖恩。
So my husband, who's my business partner, my partner in all things, Max, you guys have all met Max. Sure, yeah. Max wrote a book about fantasy football, which before fantasy football was really a big deal. He wrote a book about fantasy football and through that he met a really fun book agent
所以我的丈夫，他是我的商业伙伴，我在所有事情上的伙伴，马克斯，你们都见过马克斯。当然，是的。马克斯写了一本关于梦幻足球的书，在梦幻足球真正成为大事件之前。他写了一本关于梦幻足球的书，通过那个他遇到了一个非常有趣的图书经纪人，
and he was out to drinks with a book agent in New York who said, yeah, I've just moved over to this imprint and we're doing these silly books and I think I'm gonna, I think I'm gonna put together this book about college acapella. It's called Pitch Perfect. And Max started laughing
他和纽约的一个图书经纪人喝酒，他说，是的，我刚搬到这个印记，我们正在做这些愚蠢的书，我想我，我想我将把这本关于大学阿卡贝拉的书放在一起。它叫《完美音调》。马克斯开始笑，
because acapella was a really big thing at Penn where we went to school. Oh, really? Yeah, there was like 10 groups I can't, I mean, they were, they're overwhelmed. Of course there was. Exactly. Of course there was.
因为阿卡贝拉在我们上学的宾大是一件大事。噢，真的吗？是的，有大约10个小组，我不能，我是说，他们，他们不知所措。当然有。完全。当然有。
There's a little too much acapella. Of fucking course there was. Exactly. So, and my husband has Will's attitude, which is, I mean, but those people take it so seriously, like it's already gonna be funny. Did you see that documentary about everything was aca? Like you guys, I'm really aca mad at you.
无伴奏合唱有点太多了。当然了，肯定会有。没错。所以，我丈夫也有威尔那种态度，就是，我是说，但那些人太当真了，好像这本来会很有趣似的。你看过那部关于一切皆是无伴奏合唱的纪录片吗？就像你们，我真的对你们无伴奏合唱生气了。
I could be, you know what? They use it as an adverb. No way. Yes, oh yeah, yeah. They use aca for everything. So, you know, it was like dodgeball. Remember, was one of you in that movie? Jason was, I'm not sure.
我可以是，你知道吗？他们把它当作副词用。不会吧。是的，哦，是的，是的。他们什么都用“无伴奏合唱”（aca）这个词。所以，你知道，就像《躲避球》电影。记得吗，你们其中一人演了那部电影？杰森演了，我不确定。
Jason was in the blackout when he made that. That was actually during a lunch hour while we were shooting Arrested Development. Yeah, that's great, you were the commentator, right? Like I was playing. Yeah, I was a cotton or skater or something crazy. You were aca great. Yes.
杰森拍那部戏时喝断片了。那其实是在我们拍摄《发展受阻》的午休时间。是的，那太棒了，你是评论员，对吧？就像我在玩一样。是的，我演了个棉花球还是溜冰者之类的疯狂角色。你演得无伴奏合唱般精彩。是的。
So we, dodgeball was actually a good model for a pitch in that it's about a group of people who take something very seriously that should never be taken as seriously as they take it, right? And the coming together of a group and it's really a sports movie kind of dressed up. It's a comedy dressed up in a sports movie dressed up in a musical is what Pitch Perfect is.
所以我们，《躲避球》其实是一个很好的推介模板，因为它讲的是一群人对某件事非常认真，而这件事根本不该被如此认真对待，对吧？还有一群人的凝聚力，它本质上是一部披着运动电影外衣的电影。它是一部披着运动电影外衣，又披着音乐电影外衣的喜剧，这就是《完美音调》。
And so anyway, so we got this book proposal that Mickey Raffkin wrote. He was a writer at GQ at the time and he'd actually interviewed me for GQ like two weeks before or something. So that kind of synchronicity I always find like it's like a signpost in Hollywood. Like, oh, you shouldn't probably do this
总之，我们收到了米奇·拉夫金写的书稿。他当时是《GQ》的撰稿人，就在两周前他还为《GQ》采访过我。所以我总是觉得这种同步性就像好莱坞的路标。就像，哦，你可能不该做这个。
because you just have a signpost. And we actually didn't get the whole town, somebody else had the book proposal as well. And somehow we got universal. And so we took it out and we needed a writer. And I had just started doing 30 Rock. Will knows about that. And Kay Cannon was one of the writers in 30 Rock
因为你刚看到一个路标。我们其实没拿到整个版权，别人也有这个书稿。不知怎么的，我们拿到了环球影业的版权。所以我们把它拿出来，需要一个编剧。我刚开始做《我为喜剧狂》。威尔知道那件事。凯·坎农是《我为喜剧狂》的编剧之一。
and I was friends with Jason, her then husband. They're no longer together. Lots of things have happened in Hollywood with all of these people. Kay Cannon, who went on to make blockers. She's now a director in her own right. And now Cinderella, she's now a director too, exactly. She's an incredible funny writer and yeah, yeah, yeah.
我和她当时的丈夫杰森是朋友。他们现在不在一起了。好莱坞这些人身上发生了很多事。凯·坎农，后来制作了《护航父母》。她现在自己也是导演了。还有现在的《灰姑娘》，她也是导演了，没错。她是一位极其风趣的编剧，是的，是的，是的。
So funny. So she was one of Tina Fey's like proje's on 30 Rock at the time. And they had made acapella jokes on 30 Rock. So I knew that she knew. And so we ended up, I called her and I was like, do you, have you ever heard of acapella? She's literally, I think she went,
太搞笑了。所以她当时是蒂娜·菲在《我为喜剧狂》里的得意门生之一。他们在《我为喜剧狂》里开过无伴奏合唱的玩笑。所以我知道她懂。最后，我给她打了电话，我说，你，你听说过无伴奏合唱吗？她真的，我想她当时，
oh, on the phone and started singing. And I knew we had found it. And she came to our house in LA from New York. We sat around the dining room table. We put together a pitch and we went out with it. And we sold it. And that's what happened. That's amazing.
哦，在电话里就开始唱了起来。我就知道我们找对人了。她从纽约来到我们在洛杉矶的家。我们围坐在餐桌旁。我们整理了一个推介方案，然后就去推销了。我们就把它卖出去了。事情就是这样发生的。太棒了。
Was there ever a moment when you were gonna play one of the singer girls? No, no, no, I never, I was, we wrote the role that I play in the movie we wrote for Kristen Wiig actually. We wrote for Wiig and probably one of you guys. And then, and I ended up doing it with John Michael Higgins cause I had worked with Michael Higgins.
有没有那么一刻你想过要演其中一个唱歌的女孩？不，不，不，我从来没有，我们写了我在电影里演的那个角色，其实是为克里斯汀·韦格写的。我们是为韦格和你们中的某个人写的。最后，我跟约翰·迈克尔·希金斯一起演了，因为我跟迈克尔·希金斯合作过。
Yeah, it's so funny. And he was doing the Chris Guest stuff that he does. It was like a great template for your stuff too. Absolutely. And he did one of the greatest improv's that I'd ever seen live, like in reality. We were on the set of a very not good movie
是的，太搞笑了。他在做他那种克里斯·盖斯特风格的东西。那对你的东西来说也是个很好的模板。绝对是。他做了我现场见过最棒的即兴表演之一，真的。我们在一部非常烂的电影片场，
called Fred Claus, Vince Vaughn starred in that movie and five Oscar winners, just if we're counting. And then me and John Michael Higgins. So we were making this movie and the scene was Vince and John Michael Higgins in a bar and Vince started improving about teaching John Michael Higgins how to woo me, which is what happens in the movie.
叫《圣诞坏公公》，文斯·沃恩主演，还有五个奥斯卡得主，如果我们算上的话。然后是我和约翰·迈克尔·希金斯。我们在拍那部电影，那场戏是文斯和约翰·迈克尔·希金斯在酒吧里，文斯开始即兴表演，教约翰·迈克尔·希金斯如何追求我，这就是电影里发生的事。
And so. There's not a lot of people better than Vince at this, what are you about to say? But John matched him. So Vince says this whole thing that, so it starts like this. He's like, listen, listen buddy, you're in a Mexican standoff with this woman
所以。没几个人比文斯更擅长这个了，你要说什么？但约翰接住了他的戏。所以文斯说了整段话，开头是这样的。他说，听着，听着伙计，你现在和这个女人处于一种墨西哥式的僵局，
and you gotta bring her to the table and you gotta figure out how to like, blah, blah, blah, blah, and you know how he goes. He just goes on and on in the Vince way that he does is genius and everything or whatever. And he kind of pauses and John Michael Higgins like looks back at me. I'm off camera like over here.
你得把她带到谈判桌前，你得想办法，巴拉巴拉，你知道他怎么说的。他就像文斯那样滔滔不绝，简直是天才，诸如此类。他停顿了一下，约翰·迈克尔·希金斯回头看着我。我当时在镜头外，就在这边。
He looks back at me and turns back and he goes, gosh, she does not look Mexican. They did not. Yes, and did Vince pick up the ball there or did he just say, well, you just ruined the bit. I think. You ruined the improv. We kind of all fell out, honestly.
他回头看着我，又转回去说，天哪，她看起来一点也不像墨西哥人。他们没接住。是的，文斯接住那个梗了吗，还是他说，好吧，你毁了这个段子。我想是。你毁了即兴表演。老实说，我们都笑场了。
The whole crew fell out. I mean, it was just the perfect, it was like he held it, you know, an improv when you grab it and you hold it and you go like, where's my opening? Where's my opening? And he just held onto it the whole time and he dropped it right at the exact moment.
整个剧组都笑场了。我的意思是，那太完美了，就像他抓住了它，你知道即兴表演时你抓住它，你拿着它，然后你走，我的切入点在哪？我的切入点在哪？他一直拿着它，然后在最恰当的时刻抛了出来。
Right now, Tracy's nodding. Nodding, yeah. Perfect setup. Oh, I know what you mean. Exactly what that means, yeah. Oh, it was beautiful. That's really cool. That's such a great story.
现在，特雷西在点头。点头，是的。完美的铺垫。哦，我知道你的意思。完全明白那意味着什么，是的。哦，太美妙了。那真的很酷。那真是个很棒的故事。
Waiting for the perfect, sorry. So here's the other thing that you may be surprised or not surprised. So Scotty, my husband, Scotty and I, we love. Wait, what? Yeah, he's Scotty. Oh yeah, sorry. Elizabeth, Sean's gay.
等待完美的，抱歉。所以还有一件事你可能会惊讶，也可能不会。所以斯科蒂，我丈夫，斯科蒂和我，我们喜欢。等等，什么？是的，他是斯科蒂。哦，是的，抱歉。伊丽莎白，肖恩是同性恋。
Well, can we pause our record for one second? So we like game shows. We're old people who like game shows. We watch stuff all night long and it goes without saying. We watch you and press your luck all the time because we just can't get enough and you're so great on it and we love it. And I want to ask you what made you want to do it
好吧，我们能暂停录音一秒钟吗？我们喜欢游戏节目。我们是喜欢游戏节目的老年人。我们整晚都在看节目，不用说。我们一直看你主持的《Press Your Luck》，因为我们百看不厌，你在上面表现得太棒了，我们很喜欢。我想问你是什么让你想做这个，
because you're so good at it. And also, what do you think about this trend of big talent like yourself doing game shows? Like Will Arnett, Jamie Foxx, Alec Baldwin, yourself. A lot of people are doing these and it's all, it all works. Like I love all of them. I did, I actually was inspired partly by Will and his and when he did relaunch the show,
因为你太擅长了。还有，你怎么看像你这样的大牌明星去做游戏节目的趋势？比如威尔·阿奈特、杰米·福克斯、亚历克·鲍德温，还有你自己。很多人都在做这些，而且效果都很好。我喜欢他们所有人。我，我其实部分受到了威尔和他重启那个节目的启发，
which was, I was on, yeah, the gong show and I was on. Very kindly. The Mike Myers of it all was so incredible. I feel like we could tell stories about that for over eight years. Spoiler alert, that was pretty wild. Mike Myers was disguised as the host, yeah. Was there ever an episode when he pulled the mask off,
也就是，我参加了，是的，那个《锣声秀》，我参加了。非常客气。迈克·梅尔斯在里面的表现太不可思议了。我觉得我们可以讲八年关于那个的故事。剧透预警，那太疯狂了。迈克·梅尔斯伪装成主持人，是的。有没有哪一集他把面具摘下来，
like dug his finger into the prosthetic and... No, and it was so cool because we were like, obviously we thought it would be great to get Mike and then he was like, I'll do it, but I want to do it in this character. And Sony's like, he wants to do it in the character. I'm like, yeah, great, fucking say how, I can't say yes, hard enough.
比如手指戳进假体里……没有，而且太酷了，因为我们显然觉得能请到迈克会很棒，然后他说，我愿意做，但我想要以这个角色来做。索尼说，他想以这个角色来做。我说，是的，太棒了，该死，我怎么能拒绝呢。
Yes, let's go, but they were all really cool. And ABC, where you do your show too, they were all really cool about it. And of course I got to feel like you're some, at some point people are going to look back and go, you know, Mike Myers hosted a game show in character. And everybody's going to go, what? Nobody's making a big deal, enough, big, anyway.
是的，我们走吧，但他们都很酷。还有ABC，你也在那里做节目，他们对此都很酷。当然，我觉得在某个时刻人们会回过头来说，你知道吗，迈克·梅尔斯曾以角色身份主持过游戏节目。每个人都会说，什么？没人把它当回事，足够，大，总之。
So you did come and do it very graciously. I did. Kamie did it, we're awesome and participated in that. And then, but you were already talking to them about doing, press your luck at that point. Well, I was talking to them about doing a name that tune and like rebooting name that tune, which didn't end up coming to fruition.
所以你确实非常优雅地去做了。我做了。卡米也做了，我们很棒，也参与了。然后，但你当时已经在和他们谈做《Press Your Luck》了。嗯，我当时在和他们谈做《Name That Tune》，重启《Name That Tune》，但最终没能实现。
But then... Well, it's out now, yeah, but yeah. And now, yeah, not with me though. Right. Not with me. Right, right, right. We started talking about it. And then, yeah, and then pressure luck came on.
但后来……嗯，现在播出了，是的，但……现在，是的，不过不是我主持。对。不是我。对，对，对。我们开始谈论它。然后，是的，然后《Press Your Luck》就来了。
I loved pressure luck growing up. It was like, I was a latchkey kid, so to go home after school and like get to watch the know anything and I loved it. So I was already a fan. And I went to work, I remember the first day, I really didn't know what to totally expect. I was in the same block.
我从小就喜欢《Press Your Luck》。我小时候是个挂钥匙的孩子，所以放学回家就能看，什么都不懂，但我很喜欢。所以我已经是粉丝了。我去上班，记得第一天，我真的不知道该期待什么。我在同一个档期。
I was told, you're going to be in a block with Alec Baldwin and Steve Harvey and me and pressure luck. And I love those two gentlemen and I love their shows. And I thought, okay, well, I can't, that's pretty good. I'm not the loser in that. And I went to work the first day. We shoot like three shows a day.
有人告诉我，你要和亚历克·鲍德温、史蒂夫·哈维还有我一起在《Press Your Luck》的档期。我喜欢那两位绅士，也喜欢他们的节目。我想，好吧，我不能，那还不错。我不是其中的输家。我第一天去上班。我们一天拍三集节目。
It's exhausting. And I came home and I was in the shower, remember, and my husband came in and he was like, how was it? And I... I'm naked. Can we talk about this later? I'm in the shower for fuck's sake.
太累人了。我回家后在洗澡，记得吗，我丈夫进来了，他问，怎么样？我……我没穿衣服。我们能晚点谈这个吗？该死，我在洗澡呢。
I was naked. Guys, we had a conversation about pressure luck while I was naked in the shower. And I was started crying in the shower. And I was like, it was the most amazing day of my life. Oh, that's great. We had given away like $700,000 to a bunch of people whose lives were completely and utterly changed
我没穿衣服。伙计们，我在洗澡没穿衣服的时候讨论了《Press Your Luck》。我在淋浴时开始哭。我说，那是我一生中最美妙的一天。哦，那太棒了。我们给一群人送出了大约70万美元，他们的生活被彻底改变了，
by game show money. Like I think you forget when you're watching it, the real people that show up, that go through the motions to get there. And that are hoping to win. And then like, you're like, here you go, here's a car. And a bunch of money. I cry at that shit.
因为游戏节目的奖金。我觉得你看节目时会忘记，那些真正出现的人，他们经历了多少才走到那一步。他们希望能赢。然后你就像，给你，这是一辆车。还有一大笔钱。我为那些事哭。
I cry when people win and all that money. It's so great. Has anyone ever done a follow up on how that all went for these folks? This life changing influx of money, yeah? We do, we, they all, I mean, everything gets tweeted and Instagramed and all that. So we had this one contestant,
当人们赢了那么多钱时，我会哭。太棒了。有没有人做过后续报道，看看这些人后来怎么样了？这笔改变人生的钱，是的？我们做，他们都，我的意思是，一切都会被发到推特和Instagram上。所以我们有位参赛者，
no whammy for Pammy, maybe Sean remembers. So Pam was a big share fan. And we gave her an all expenses paid, private jet to Vegas, three shares nights in a row. I saw that show, it's an unbelievable show. Yeah, she's great. And this woman lost her mind. She got to bring her friends.
“帕米没有炸弹”（No whammy for Pammy），也许肖恩记得。帕姆是雪儿的超级粉丝。我们给了她全额报销的私人飞机去拉斯维加斯，连续三晚看雪儿的演唱会。我看了那期节目，那是个令人难以置信的节目。是的，她太棒了。这个女人简直疯了。她带上了她的朋友。
She also won a guest wardrobe, because that was her favorite clothes. And so she wore her guest clothes and went to share and like posted it all. It was amazing. And like, that's all she ever wanted in life was to go see Cher and a private jet with her friends. And like, we were like, here you go.
她还赢得了雪儿的服装，因为那是她最喜欢的衣服。所以她穿着雪儿的衣服去看了雪儿的演唱会，还发了照片。太神奇了。那真的是她一生中唯一想要的，就是和朋友坐私人飞机去看雪儿。我们就像，给你。
And that all happened, yeah. Yeah, you make it happen. It's incredible. I absolutely love hosting a game show. I love it. It's one of my favorite things. So that's, so that's, and so interesting. Now, do you, is there something that you-
这一切都发生了，是的。是的，你让它发生了。太不可思议了。我绝对喜欢主持游戏节目。我喜欢它。这是我最喜欢的事情之一。所以这就是，所以这就是，太有趣了。现在，你，有什么你……
Thank you for watching, Sean Hayes. Of course, I love it. Is there something that you kind of, it seems like you've been immersed into the world of Hollywood, like you said at the beginning, where it's once you're in it, it's like, what else do I do?
感谢观看，肖恩·海耶斯。当然，我喜欢它。有没有什么你，看起来你已经沉浸在好莱坞的世界里了，就像你开头说的，一旦你进来了，就像，我还能做什么？
I don't have any other skills. Is there anything you always wanted to do or that you are still want to do, or is it 24 seven Hollywood directing produce? Like you just love it so much. I mean, I don't know that I love it so, so much. Yeah. But it's the only thing that you're doing.
我没有其他技能。有没有什么你一直想做或者仍然想做的事情，还是说24小时全天候好莱坞导演和制片？就像你太爱它了。我的意思是，我不知道我是否那么那么爱它。是的。但这是你唯一在做的事情。
Everything. Sean really made it out like Hollywood should just be loved up. Like, like I'm rubbing up on it all the time. Every night. No, just because of your journey from school to then getting a master's to then New York to just working all the time.
一切。肖恩真的表现得好像好莱坞就应该被爱一样。就像，我一直都在蹭它。每天晚上。不，只是因为你从学校到拿到硕士学位，再到纽约，再到一直工作。
Is it, is it, is your life fulfilled in that way? Is kind of what I meant. Or is there more that you've always wanted to do? I mean, I'm one of those people, I feel like you guys are, I mean, why did you start this podcast? You know, it's like, what else is there to do? Yeah, there's that.
是，是，你的生活以那种方式充实了吗？这就是我的意思。还是说有更多你一直想做的事情？我的意思是，我是那种人，我觉得你们也是，我的意思是，你们为什么要开这个播客？你知道，就像，还有什么可做的？是的，有那个。
You know, honestly, we're all very similarly aged too. I have come to the point in my life where I'm like, all right, I mean, 50 more years. Like, what are we doing now for the rest of it? Like, you know. Right. Do you guys ever let your imagination go to that, that whenever that fork was in your life,
你知道，老实说，我们年龄也都差不多。我生命中已经到了这样一个阶段，我想，好吧，我的意思是，再过50年。就像，我们现在余生要做什么？就像，你知道。对。你们有没有让你们的想象力去想，当你们生命中出现那个分叉路口时，
you know, whether it was college or before or a little bit after where you could pick where you're gonna kind of put your energy. And if you could switch that and point it somewhere else, what was close to maybe gonna be your career? Or if you could go back knowing what you know now and what you love now, would you have put your energies into architecture or politics or anything
你知道，无论是大学还是之前，或者之后一点，你可以选择把精力放在哪里。如果你能切换并指向别处，什么可能接近你的职业？或者如果你能带着现在的知识和现在的热爱回到过去，你会把精力投入到建筑、政治或任何
that's even remotely interesting to you that can compare? Nope, no. I think being a storyteller is an incredible job. And I love it. And I remember being taught in college that storytelling, you know, that it's the oldest form, it's not just entertainment, but like, you know, they used to sit around the fire in the caves
哪怕有一点点让你感兴趣、能与之相比的事情上吗？不，没有。我认为成为一名讲故事的人是一份了不起的工作。我热爱它。我记得在大学里学到讲故事，你知道，这是最古老的形式，它不仅仅是娱乐，而是像，你知道，他们过去围坐在洞穴里的火堆旁，
and someone would get up and be the storyteller and be like, there's lions and this is how you avoid that. You know, it's literally like how we, why we are humans is because we have storytelling, because we have imaginations, because we create characters, right? And so to me, it's such a gift of a job to do every day. It's incredible.
有人会站起来成为讲故事的人，说，有狮子，这是你如何避免的方法。你知道，这简直就是我们，为什么我们是人类，是因为我们有讲故事的能力，因为我们有想象力，因为我们创造角色，对吧？所以对我来说，每天做这份工作真是一份礼物。太不可思议了。
Right, but if that guy who got up, he's telling a story, well, if he falls over into the fire, he burns himself, he's gonna have to sue the guy that didn't put the rock wall up high. Who's gonna represent him? So, you know, lawyers came around and eventually things filled out. That's right, we had to fill out civilization
对，但如果那个站起来讲故事的人，他掉进火里，他烧伤了自己，他得起诉那个没把石墙砌高的人。谁来代表他？所以，你知道，律师出现了，最终事情完善了。没错，我们不得不围绕那个特定的人完善文明。
around that particular guy. I just mean to say like, it's an old tradition and it's being carried on by all of us and it's a fun responsibility, I think. And I don't take it too seriously as you guys know, I really am just trying to entertain people at the end. I would say, so one of my favorite things about you is that how you don't take it, and you mentioned that,
我只是想说，这是一个古老的传统，我们所有人都在传承它，我认为这是一项有趣的责任。而且我不会太当真，正如你们所知，我真的只是想在最后娱乐大众。我会说，所以你最让我喜欢的一点是，你不把它，你提到了这一点，
and or yourself too seriously. And it's always one of the most sort of, it's almost disarming how sort of open and genuine you are as a person. I always sort of, you sort of forget because you do, as Jason said, you do have this incredible career and you've done so many amazing things.
或者你自己太当真。而且它总是最，某种程度上，你作为一个人的开放和真诚是如此令人卸下防备。我总是某种程度上，你某种程度上会忘记，因为你，正如杰森所说，你确实有这样令人难以置信的职业生涯，你做了这么多令人惊叹的事情。
And then anytime I spent any time with you, I was like, oh God, you're so down earth and so normal and so funny. And I felt comfortable enough to let you in on my, when I was on the dating app and everything and we remember that whole thing, and you checked up to see how it was going. Let's pull over here for a second.
然后任何时候我和你在一起，我就想，哦天哪，你太脚踏实地，太正常，太风趣了。我感到足够舒服，让你参与到我的，当我在约会软件上时，一切，我们记得那整件事，你还查看了进展如何。让我们在这里停一下。
You got it. So there you are on, so you're on Raya and you swipe and you see Liz Banks on there and you're like, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no. The story's about it, the story's about it, the story's about it, the story's about it. I was living vicariously through Will. He was getting to be on dating apps,
你懂的。所以你就在，所以你在Raya上，你滑动，你看到莉兹·班克斯在上面，你就想，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不。故事是关于它的，故事是关于它的，故事是关于它的，故事是关于它的。我通过威尔过着代理生活。他能用约会软件，
Raya being the main one. And I was like, I wanna look at some of these ladies. I wanna swipe. And one of the things I found fascinating was how every dating profile is the same. So like every girl is like in a bikini by eating a pizza or like holding a duck. They're like always like in bed under the covers
Raya是主要的那个。我就想，我想看看这些女士。我想滑动。我发现最迷人的一件事是每个约会资料都一样。所以每个女孩都像穿着比基尼吃披萨，或者像抱着一只鸭子。她们总是像在床上盖着被子，
but with a dog, like they're all the same. Like there's no bad ideas, yeah. And then it's all listed like their job but they're all philanthropists too. They're all like, well, all the dudes say that they're philanthropists because what they're trying to say is like, I got a lot of dough.
但抱着一只狗，就像她们都一样。就像没有坏主意，是的。然后她们都列出了自己的工作，但她们也都是慈善家。她们都像，嗯，所有的男人都说他们是慈善家，因为他们想表达的是，我有很多钱。
Yeah, and every guys with like a kid but it's usually like, look, I'm a great uncle. So it's like you're great with kids but you're hot but your abs are out but you eat pizza but you love animals but you're cool and you lay in bed and you'll like a photo and you have messy hair. Like it was amazing.
是的，每个男人都带着一个孩子，但通常就像，看，我是个很棒的叔叔。所以就像你很擅长带孩子，但你很性感，但你的腹肌露出来了，但你吃披萨，但你爱动物，但你很酷，你躺在床上，你会点赞一张照片，你有凌乱的头发。就像这太神奇了。
It's amazing. So we went on this trip to promote the second Lego movie and it was me and Liz and... Chris Pratt. Well, Chris Pratt and Corden. Oh yeah, sorry. You guys went to space camp? Yeah, we went to space camp.
太神奇了。所以我们去了一次旅行来宣传第二部《乐高大电影》，是我和莉兹，还有……克里斯·帕拉特。嗯，克里斯·帕拉特和柯登。哦，是的，抱歉。你们去太空营了？是的，我们去了太空营。
Oh my God, I saw that. It was hilarious. And so we were there. First of all, I don't know if you remember this. So Corden says, I was like, I had the app open. I'd just gotten it and I was like, okay and you could kind of message to people who you matched with or whatever.
哦，天哪，我看到了。太搞笑了。所以我们在那里。首先，我不知道你记不记得这个。所以柯登说，我当时，我打开了那个软件。我刚得到它，我就想，好吧，你可以给和你匹配的人发信息之类的。
And Corden said, whatever happens in this next one you have to message exactly what I say. Do you remember that? So I was like, okay. So Corden says, this girl's like, hey, how's it going? And he's like, you have to answer. Well, I just stepped off a helicopter so it's going pretty well.
柯登说，接下来发生什么，你必须准确地发送我说的话。你记得吗？所以我当时想，好吧。所以柯登说，这个女孩说，嘿，最近怎么样？他说，你必须回答。嗯，我刚从直升机上下来，所以一切都很顺利。
So I put that in there. And imagine being on the receiving end of this girl being like, okay, you dick. I'm in Ireland right now, you guys. What? I forgot to mention. You're in Ireland right now? You guys, I live in a cottage by the Irish Sea.
所以我把它放进去了。想象一下作为这个女孩的接收端，就像，好吧，你这个混蛋。我现在在爱尔兰，你们。什么？我忘了提了。你现在在爱尔兰？你们，我住在爱尔兰海边的一个小屋里。
Like that's. What is going on there? Okay, you guys. I'm making a movie called Cocaine Bear. Yes. You're making Cocaine Bear. Yes. We're making Cocaine Bear.
就像那是。那里发生了什么？好吧，你们。我正在拍一部叫《可卡因熊》的电影。是的。你在拍《可卡因熊》。是的。我们正在拍《可卡因熊》。
Have you started shooting yet? Are you in pre-production? No, I'm in prep. We start shooting in August. Yeah. Are you directing this? I am, yeah. I'm directing the movie.
你们开始拍摄了吗？你们在前期制作吗？不，我在准备阶段。我们八月开始拍摄。是的。你在导演这部电影吗？我是，是的。我在导演这部电影。
Oh, that's great. Who's in it? What's it about? We, it's about, it's based on a true story, Sean. This is an incredible story about an infamous drug runner whose whole MO was that he would drop drugs out of an airplane like a Cessna that he would fly up from Columbia with Coke in it.
哦，那太棒了。谁在里面？它是关于什么的？我们，它是关于，它基于一个真实故事，肖恩。这是一个关于一个臭名昭著的毒贩的不可思议的故事，他的整个作案手法是他会把毒品从飞机上扔下来，就像他从哥伦比亚飞上来的塞斯纳飞机，里面装着可卡因。
He would drop it over fields to get picked up along the East coast. And then he would parachute out of the plane and then dump the plane into the Atlantic Ocean. So, you know, they would do drug runs worth like 100s of millions of dollars. And these Cessnas are like $2 million planes. So it was cost of doing business.
他会把它扔在田野上，以便在东海岸被捡走。然后他会跳伞离开飞机，然后把飞机扔进大西洋。所以，你知道，他们会进行价值数亿美元的毒品运输。而这些塞斯纳飞机就像200万美元的飞机。所以这是做生意的成本。
They'd get rid of the plane. So if anybody had tracked it or whatever, it's the equivalent of like lighting the car on fire with where the crime had occurred. And he was able to do this because he was a paratrooper in the army and he had a whole special set of skills. And so one day, you guys will love this story. He flew the plane back from Columbia.
他们会处理掉飞机。所以如果有人追踪它之类的，这相当于在犯罪发生的地方点燃汽车。他能做到这一点是因为他是军队里的伞兵，他有一整套特殊的技能。所以有一天，你们会喜欢这个故事。他从哥伦比亚飞回飞机。
He had brought to Columbia his karate instructor. And the two of them had had parrot while they were in Columbia. They were sick on the plane. They were puking everywhere. They decided they needed to dish this plane. And the karate instructor jumped out and landed and was fine.
他带了他的空手道教练去哥伦比亚。他们两个在哥伦比亚时吃了鹦鹉。他们在飞机上病了。他们到处呕吐。他们决定他们需要抛弃这架飞机。空手道教练跳了出去，着陆了，没事。
And then Andrew C. Thornton II, the infamous drug runner jumped out, apparently hit his head on the plane, never deployed his chute. His emergency chute deployed. He ended up dead on the ground, surrounded by drugs with like Gucci loafers. This was all in 1985.
然后安德鲁·C·桑顿二世，那个臭名昭著的毒贩跳了出去，显然撞到了飞机，降落伞没打开。他的紧急降落伞打开了。他最终死在地上，周围都是毒品，穿着古驰乐福鞋。这一切都发生在1985年。
And the police and the mob, suddenly were like, he just dropped a bunch of drugs because the police never had any clues about where he'd done anything. So now he falls from the sky and like, we gotta go find the bags of drugs. And they never found the drugs actually. And we don't know if the mob picked it up or what happened.
警察和黑帮突然觉得，他刚扔了一堆毒品，因为警察从来没有任何关于他在哪里做过任何事的线索。所以现在他从天而降，就像，我们得去找到那些毒品袋。他们实际上从来没找到毒品。我们不知道是黑帮捡走了还是发生了什么。
But three months later, they found a black bear in the Chattahoochee National Forest in Georgia, surrounded by bags of drugs. And he had died from a massive drug overdose. He had eaten $17 million worth of cocaine. The bear. The bear did. The bear did.
但三个月后，他们在佐治亚州的查塔胡奇国家森林发现了一只黑熊，周围都是毒品袋。它死于严重的药物过量。它吃了价值1700万美元的可卡因。那只熊。那只熊。
Yeah. And he's now, that bear was called Jason Bateman. There are a lot of jokes about who the cocaine bear was in 1985. It definitely could have been Bateman. Are you in the movie too or just directing? No, I'm just going to direct it. And who is in it? Ray Liotta, plays in the mob. Oh my God, I love Ray Liotta.
是的。它现在，那只熊叫杰森·贝特曼。关于1985年谁是可卡因熊有很多笑话。那绝对可能是贝特曼。你也在电影里吗，还是只导演？不，我只是要导演它。谁在里面？雷·利奥塔，演黑帮。哦，天哪，我爱雷·利奥塔。
Yeah. Carrie Russell. Love Carrie Russell, I love Carrie. I love her. She's one of my all-time faves. Oh, a delightful human. Did she work with her will? I did. I know her very well.
是的。凯丽·拉塞尔。爱凯丽·拉塞尔，我爱凯丽。我爱她。她是我有史以来最喜欢的人之一。哦，一个令人愉快的人。她和威尔合作过吗？我合作过。我非常了解她。
She's a good friend. Say hi to her for me, please. I will. I know. I love her and Matthew. Matthew's a great cut to you. All great. Jesse Tala Ferguson, I think, is going to be hit. Fantastic. Because we're very old friends and I-
她是个好朋友。请替我向她问好。我会的。我知道。我爱她和马修。马修是个很棒的剪辑。都很棒。杰西·泰勒·弗格森，我想，会很火。因为我们是老朋友，我……
He's hilarious. He's hilarious. Alden Ehrenreich is going to be in the movie. He was Han Solo. Sure. Oh, sure. He's fantastic. I love that.
他太搞笑了。他太搞笑了。阿尔登·埃伦瑞奇会出现在电影里。他是韩·索罗。当然。哦，当然。他太棒了。我喜欢那个。
He's a very good actor. Yeah, I mean- So it's got a really fun cut. Then a bunch of young kids. It's like a bunch of young kids that go- That's fun. It seems like a kid's movie. Very stand by me in this movie, yeah.
他是个非常好的演员。是的，我的意思是……所以它有一个非常有趣的剪辑。然后是一群年轻人。就像一群年轻人去……那很有趣。看起来像一部儿童电影。非常像《伴我同行》这部电影，是的。
Really? Yeah. So Liz, you're off doing this movie, this cocaine beer. I heard about this. I'm so excited. I just, I can't, I just, I told you before, I just think the world here.
真的吗？是的。所以莉兹，你去做这部电影，这部可卡因熊。我听说了。我太兴奋了。我只是，我不能，我只是，我之前告诉过你，我只是认为世界在这里。
I just think that you're just so funny and cool and- Here comes the butt. I just want to, no, there's no butt. I was going to say, I just want to do something. I want to be at your disposal at some point. I want you to tell me, I want you to direct a movie with me, not with Sean and Jason.
我只是认为你太风趣和酷了，而且……转折来了。我只是想，不，没有转折。我本来想说，我只是想做点什么。我想在某个时候听候你的差遣。我想让你告诉我，我想让你导演一部有我的电影，不是和肖恩和杰森一起。
Not with Sean and Jason. I just want to be a supporting character. I just want to be there to have fun. Sean and I are holding out for a Pitch Perfect 3. Is 3 on its way? It was a 3. 3 happens. 3 happens.
不是和肖恩和杰森一起。我只想做一个配角。我只想在那里玩得开心。肖恩和我在等待《完美音调3》。3在路上了吗？那是3。3发生了。3发生了。
Is 4, let me finish. Is 4 on its way? 4. We'll make a deal right now. I'll self-tape right now. I think we'll self-tape. No, this is a self-tape. This is it.
4在路上了吗？4。我们现在就做个交易。我现在就自拍。我想我们会自拍。不，这是自拍。就是这个。
We're self-tapping right now. Sing right now, Jason. Sing for real. I sing the body electric. Which was a song that was great and wonderful, because if we don't talk about a song we have to pay for. That's a fantastic song. I sing something else from fame.
我们现在正在自拍。现在唱歌，杰森。真的唱。我唱《Body Electric》。这是一首很棒很美妙的歌，因为如果我们不谈论一首歌，我们就得付钱。那是一首美妙的歌。我唱《Fame》里的其他东西。
And what is the song? It's such a wonderful thing. Stop singing and start talking. What is the song? That song is from, is that from hair? No, that's from fame. That's what I meant. Yep.
那首歌是什么？那是一件美妙的事情。别唱了，开始说话。那首歌是什么？那首歌来自，那是来自《Hair》吗？不，那是来自《Fame》。我就是那个意思。是的。
By the way, hey, how about you remake fame? I remember that. I remember that, right? Was that Alan Parker? You guys, oh, that's so, I have no idea what a great segue that is, because I talk about fame on my podcast, My Body, My Podcast, exclusively on Audible. And they, because fame literally rocked my life
顺便说一句，嘿，你重拍《Fame》怎么样？我记得那个。我记得那个，对吧？那是艾伦·帕克吗？你们，哦，那太，我不知道那是一个多么棒的过渡，因为我在我的播客《My Body, My Podcast》中谈论《Fame》，独家在Audible上。他们，因为《Fame》真的震撼了我的生活，
when I saw fame in so many ways. And not because it was about a group of people who really wanted to pursue, to live in the ats, to work in the ats. It was people who wanted to live forever, who wanted to learn how to fly. Exactly. Not because of those things, even though I was inspired.
当我看到《Fame》时，在很多方面。不是因为它是一个关于一群真正想追求，想住在艺术里，想在艺术里工作的人的故事。是那些想永远活着，想学习如何飞翔的人。没错。不是因为那些事情，尽管我受到了启发。
No, it's because Irene Cara is topples in that movie. I don't know if you guys remember that part. Oh, we do. No, no, I never knew that. Well, there was always the TV version that I feel like you got to watch. I got to watch it on HBO back in the day when HBO was like a new thing.
不，是因为艾琳·卡拉在那部电影里上身赤裸。我不知道你们是否记得那部分。哦，我们记得。不，不，我从来不知道。嗯，总是有电视版本，我觉得你可以看。我过去在HBO还是个新东西的时候在HBO看过。
I was old enough. I was in the theater. And we got like, my family could never afford HBO, but we would get the free weekends, you know? And I'm pretty sure that it was on one of the free weekends. So I watched it. And Irene Cara is topples. And I do an entire podcast about this.
我够大了。我在剧院里。我们得到像，我的家人从来买不起HBO，但我们会得到免费周末，你知道吗？我很确定它是在一个免费周末播出的。所以我看了。艾琳·卡拉上身赤裸。我为此做了一个完整的播客。
I'm not joking. Every episode is about fame? Yeah. I was being about Irene Cara specifically. I was being bullied back then. I was really skinny. And I was very behind in puberty. I still am.
我没开玩笑。每一集都是关于《Fame》的？是的。我当时是专门关于艾琳·卡拉的。我当时被欺负。我真的很瘦。而且我在青春期方面非常落后。我现在还是。
It's coming along nicely. It's coming along nicely. This is the whole point. They never came along. Your voice still hasn't dropped. They never came along. And I was being bullied by this girl named Erica. And she heard the insult that she hurled at me after school
它发展得很好。它发展得很好。这就是重点。它们从来没有发展。你的声音还没变。它们从来没有发展。我被一个叫埃里卡的女孩欺负。她听到了放学后她对我说的侮辱，
when she would bull me out on the way home, was you're going to have cone boobs. And I didn't know what that meant. Like Madonna's cones have not come out. Yeah, that wasn't a thing. I didn't know what a cone-shaped boob was at the time. Because I just looked at sports illustrated swimsuit edition.
当她在回家的路上欺负我时，是你会长圆锥形的胸部。我不知道那意味着什么。就像麦当娜的圆锥还没出来。是的，那不是一回事。我当时不知道圆锥形的胸部是什么。因为我只看了《体育画报》泳装特刊。
Those were all round. Nobody had cones in sports illustrated. And then I saw Irene Cara. And she has very, she had. I don't know. I haven't seen her body in a very long time. In fame, when she was topless, she had some very adorable small breasts
那些都是圆的。没人有圆锥形在《体育画报》里。然后我看到了艾琳·卡拉。她有非常，她有。我不知道。我很久没见过她的身体了。在《Fame》里，当她上身赤裸时，她有一些非常可爱的、小的乳房，
that were a little conical. And I kind of freaked out. I was like, that's what the bully means. And I was like, that might. OK, that's going to be me. And at the time, those were unacceptable boobs. Do you know what I mean? But wait, why?
有点圆锥形。我有点吓坏了。我想，这就是那个恶霸的意思。我想，那可能是我的。当时，那些是不可接受的胸部。你知道我的意思吗？但等等，为什么？
I mean, what? Why would all boobs are gorgeous? Of course, it makes no sense. Makes no sense. It's so dumb. It makes no sense. Of course, everybody's gorgeous. Everybody beautiful.
我的意思是，什么？为什么所有的胸部都很华丽？当然，这毫无意义。毫无意义。太蠢了。这毫无意义。当然，每个人都很华丽。每个人都很美。
And so the podcast really is about why these things seep into our brains and why we get this messaging that you should look like the cover of sports illustrated. And I've never been able to fill out that bikini top. You're doing OK. Well, you guys, then my very first big movie that you mentioned was What Had American Summer I Show Up. And David Wayne's like, we wore this bikini, I guess.
所以播客真的是关于为什么这些东西渗入我们的大脑，为什么我们得到这种信息，你应该看起来像《体育画报》的封面。我从来没能填满那个比基尼上衣。你做得还可以。好吧，你们，然后我提到的我的第一部大电影是《哈拉夏令营》。大卫·韦恩就像，我们穿了这个比基尼，我想。
And I put it on. And then the first agent I ever met in LA, because I had a New York agent, as I said, when I went to LA and I interviewed this agent, I won't name him. But he was like, have you ever thought about getting a boob job? Uh-oh. Oh, Lord. Wow.
我穿上了它。然后我在洛杉矶见到的第一个经纪人，因为我有一个纽约经纪人，正如我所说，当我去洛杉矶面试这个经纪人时，我不会说出他的名字。但他就像，你有没有想过做隆胸手术？哦哦。哦，天哪。哇。
Is he still in the business? Yeah, he is. He's still in the business? And I was like, well, the gig's kind of up, because I made this movie What Had American Summer that I'm sure tons and tons of people are going to see. By the way, no one saw that movie for like 20 years. So I was like, everyone's going to see this movie.
他还在这个行业吗？是的，他在。他还在这个行业？我就想，好吧，演出结束了，因为我拍了这部《哈拉夏令营》，我相信成千上万的人会看到。顺便说一句，没人看那部电影看了20年。所以我当时想，每个人都会看到这部电影。
And I'm already in a bikini top. So now I think it would be weird if I suddenly pop a d-cup after just showing off these little babies that I have. The New York Times is going to write a story about it. Exactly. Like, it's going to become a thing. And I can't have that happen. Meanwhile, all I was thinking to myself was, no,
而且我已经穿着比基尼上衣了。所以现在我觉得如果我突然在展示了这些我有的小宝贝之后长出D罩杯会很奇怪。《纽约时报》会写一篇关于它的报道。没错。就像，它会成为一件事。我不能让那种事发生。与此同时，我脑子里想的只是，不，
I'm not having surgery. And I don't know why we're talking about it in a movie. No fucking kidding. We live in such a fucking. But, yeah. It's not even just Hollywood. It's just this environment we live in. I have body dysmorphia myself.
我不会做手术。而且我不知道为什么我们在电影里谈论它。该死，没开玩笑。我们生活在这样一个该死的。但是，是的。这甚至不仅仅是好莱坞。这只是我们生活的环境。我自己有身体畸形恐惧症。
Show us your cones, Will. Will, can we see your cones? Anyway, fame. Fame, remake it. Fame. No, don't remake it. No, it's perfect. No, don't remake it.
给我们看看你的圆锥，威尔。威尔，我们能看看你的圆锥吗？总之，《Fame》。《Fame》，重拍它。《Fame》。不，别重拍它。不，它是完美的。不，别重拍它。
It's perfect. But don't you think that, like, you know, for people who hold on to things like that, obviously that had an effect on you and somebody said that to you and you held on to it for such a long time. Isn't it funny at some point at some age, I don't know what it is, where you go, why was I holding on?
它是完美的。但你不觉得，就像，你知道，对于那些坚持这种事情的人来说，显然那对你有影响，有人对你说了那样的话，你坚持了那么久。在某个年龄，我不知道是什么，当你去想，我为什么要坚持？
Like, who gives a shit about any of that? Like, who cares? I like me. I like my body, whatever I have. But it's hard. I mean, Shani, luckily you hit fuck it like 15 years ago, right? I hit fuck it. I'm still working on fuck it, but I'm almost there.
就像，谁在乎那些？就像，谁在乎？我喜欢我自己。我喜欢我的身体，无论我有什么。但这很难。我的意思是，肖恩，幸运的是你15年前就说了去他的，对吧？我说了去他的。我还在努力说去他的，但我快到了。
By the way, I remember one of the first places I went on the Warner Brothers lot. I was walked past all of your Porsches on Will and Grace. Yeah, how about that? People didn't hate us already. Yeah. I mean, now that is hot. Man, that's the life.
顺便说一句，我记得我去华纳兄弟片场的第一批地方之一。我走过了你们在《威尔和格蕾丝》里的所有保时捷。是的，那怎么样？人们还没讨厌我们。是的。我的意思是，现在那很火。伙计，那就是生活。
I sold mine. I sold mine. That was like 19, Sean sold his, but it was like 1999. Yeah, just to give, so Will and Grace became a hit. The same thing happened to Will and Grace's happened to Friends, which was we became a hit when they had reruns over the second summer. So it was the network recognized this
我卖了我的。我卖了我的。那是1999年，肖恩卖了他的，但那是1999年。是的，只是为了给，所以《威尔和格蕾丝》成了热门。同样的事情发生在《威尔和格蕾丝》身上，也发生在《老友记》身上，那就是我们在第二个夏天重播时成了热门。所以网络意识到了这一点，
and to award us, reward us. They gave us like four Porsches for the cast. And you're like, oh, wow, it's incredible. And then you add up how much it costs for an ad in the USA today, and it was a biased four Porsches was cheaper than an ad. And we got more press from getting the cars. Yeah, of course.
为了奖励我们。他们给了演员们四辆保时捷。你就像，哦，哇，太不可思议了。然后你算一下在《今日美国》上打广告要多少钱，四辆保时捷比广告便宜。而且我们从得到车中得到了更多的媒体报道。是的，当然。
I always said to our friend who ran to Silverman when he ran NBC, I was like, go back to giving dumb actors cars because it's way less than a fucking raise. And they're going to thank you forever. And every time you negotiate, they're going to say like, yeah, but Ben was kind of nice to me. So I'm not going to, I don't want to push it. You can't get that car that time.
我总是对我们那个经营NBC的朋友说，我当时说，回去给笨演员车吧，因为这比该死的加薪少得多。他们会永远感谢你。而且每次你谈判时，他们都会说，是的，但本对我还不错。所以我不想，我不想推它。你不能在那次得到那辆车。
I must say though, it was a very nice, generous thing. But yeah. Sean, I remember when you got those, when you got those Porsches, and as actors, I was in the same position, I was living in New York, kind of coming out to LA to work when I could and whatever. And they're like, and then I got a pilot, I was on a show and you guys were on the air.
我必须说，那是一件非常慷慨的事情。但是的。肖恩，我记得当你得到那些保时捷时，作为演员，我处于同样的位置，我住在纽约，尽可能去洛杉矶工作，无论怎样。然后他们说，然后我得到了一个试播集，我在一个节目里，你们在播出。
And I did a show for like, we got canceled up to two episodes, two areas called the Michael Malley show. So we were at the upfront with you guys were like, I love Mike. Yeah, the Mike's the best. And in love, yeah. Mike, first of all, just a second for Michael Malley, one of the all time greats.
我做了一个节目，我们被取消了，直到两集，两个区域叫《迈克尔·马利秀》。所以我们在预售会上，你们就像，我爱迈克。是的，迈克是最棒的。而且在爱里，是的。迈克，首先，给迈克尔·马利一秒钟，史上最伟大的人之一。
He's one of the all time. Boston strong, Boston strong. Boston strong. It was just a moment of silence. Is he not with us? No, no, he's still, he's doing a praise. Believing he's, he's a mitch's mitch. But anyway, but we were at the, we were at the upfront
他是史上最伟大的人之一。波士顿强，波士顿强。波士顿强。那只是默哀片刻。他不在我们身边了吗？不，不，他还在，他在做赞美。相信他，他是米奇的米奇。但总之，但我们在预售会上，
and you guys were the, the toast of the upfront, Sean, Will and Grace. I don't think we've ever talked about this. And I was like, oh man. And then somebody's like, they all got Porsches. I was like, oh man. And then they go, Porsche Boxsters. And I was like, yeah.
你们是预售会的宠儿，肖恩，威尔和格蕾丝。我不认为我们谈论过这个。我就想，哦伙计。然后有人说，他们都得到了保时捷。我就想，哦伙计。然后他们说，保时捷Boxster。我就想，是的。
Yeah. I swear to God. And I had nothing. I didn't have a fucking pot to piss in. And I was like, yeah. So just to be clear though, I couldn't pay my rent at that moment. Even after, you know, sure.
是的，我发誓。当时我一无所有，穷得叮当响。我当时就想，好吧。但要说明的是，那一刻我连房租都付不起。即使在后来，你知道的，当然。
I, we made it through one season. I was like, oh, I can kind of pay my rent now a little bit. And then we get this. It's like, no, I'm not holding onto this. I'm selling mine immediately. So I can pay my rent for the next year in case this doesn't get picked up. What do I need two cars for?
我们熬过了一季。我当时想，哦，我现在稍微能付得起一点房租了。然后我们得到了这个。就像是，不，我不能留着这个。我得马上把它卖了。这样如果节目没被续订，我至少能付得起下一年的房租。我需要两辆车干什么？
Thank you. It's very appreciative. But I'd rather a raise or something. I don't need a car. You were still on a commercial. I remember you were still on a Bud Light commercial while you were on Will and Grace. Yeah. That's a true story.
谢谢。非常感激。但我宁愿要加薪之类的。我不需要车。你当时还在拍广告。我记得你在拍《威尔和格蕾丝》的时候还在拍百威淡啤的广告。是的，那是真的。
That's a true story. Yeah. I have to say, I went to a taping of Will and Grace. And I was, yeah. And I still, I tell people about it all the time. You know, when people are like, what makes a great TV show? I'm like, the actors have to be fucking great.
那是真的。是的。我必须说，我去看过《威尔和格蕾丝》的录制。我当时，是的。我到现在还经常跟别人提起这件事。你知道，当人们问，什么才是一部伟大的电视剧？我会说，演员必须得非常棒。
You're so sweet. And they have to be written for their special thing. And then they have to have amazing chemistry. Like this is not easy. It's what you guys had in the rest of development too. But yeah, for sure. You guys were maestros. I mean, it helps to have Jim Bros there.
你太贴心了。而且剧本必须是为他们量身定做的。然后他们必须有惊人的化学反应。这可不容易。你们在《发展受阻》里也是这样。但确实，你们当时真是大师。我是说，有吉姆·伯罗斯在场很有帮助。
But man, you guys were so, it was magic to watch. That's so sweet. Did we meet? Forgive me. How you guys worked together. The four of you worked together. Sean, you were fucking great on that show. No, you really, really were.
但是伙计，你们当时真是，看你们表演简直是一种魔力。太贴心了。我们见过面吗？请原谅我。你们四个人合作的方式。肖恩，你在那部剧里真是太棒了。不，你真的，真的非常棒。
That's very sweet. I appreciate it. You guys are so funny. Everyone was virtuosistic. Truly. That's very nice. I feel the same way about everybody talking here today. I would, I'm dying to do another sitcom.
太贴心了。我很感激。你们太有趣了。每个人都是大师级水准。真的。太好了。我对今天在这里交谈的每个人都有同样的感觉。我，我渴望再拍一部情景喜剧。
Let's do it. I miss that routine. I know. And the audience and the, oh my God. I think we're kind of doing one. It's called smart men's show. Why don't we just read the four of us to do one? Let's do a sitcom next year.
我们来拍吧。我怀念那种日常。我知道。还有观众，哦天哪。我觉得我们现在就在做一部。叫《聪明人秀》。为什么我们四个不干脆读一个剧本呢？明年我们来拍一部情景喜剧吧。
Hit record. We have taken, God, we've taken up way too much of your time. You got an industry to uphold, you know? I mean. Here's what I want to say. I want to say thank you for dressing up for your other thing that you had today and keeping it on for us.
按下录音键。我们已经，天哪，占用了你太多时间了。你还有个行业要支撑，你知道吗？我是说。我想说的是，谢谢你为了今天其他的活动盛装打扮，并且为了我们一直保持着那个造型。
Keeping it on. Instead of changing into the drama. That's a great point. You look gorgeous. And you kept your hair on too. I've seen you bald. It's not fun. No, no.
一直保持着。而不是换回平时的装束。说得好。你看上去美极了。而且你还戴着假发。我见过你秃头的样子。那可不好玩。不，不。
The wig is beautiful today. Thank you so much. This one's named Doris. I think Doris is the winner. She's so pretty. You guys are the best. You're the best. We love you.
这顶假发今天很漂亮。非常感谢。这顶叫多丽丝。我觉得多丽丝是赢家。她太漂亮了。你们是最棒的。你们是最棒的。我们爱你。
Love you guys. Say hi to Max. Thank you. I will and I will love you guys too. Bye. Oh man, I've been waiting for her to come on. Yeah, she's great. I love it.
爱你们。代我向马克斯问好。谢谢。我会的，我也爱你们。再见。天哪，我一直等着她来呢。是的，她太棒了。我喜欢。
She's the best. You know what I love about her is the, she's the perfect example of picking something when you're younger that you're drawn to. And you follow it through. You're inevitably going to be successful. The earlier you pick the thing that you love, right? I suppose.
她是最好的。你知道我喜欢她哪一点吗？她是那种在年轻时就选择了自己向往的事业，并坚持到底的完美典范。你注定会成功。越早选择你热爱的事业，对吧？我想是这样。
And she went to high school, college, all of those things, master's degree. So of course she's successful because she knew she wanted to do it from day one. We didn't even really talk about what a successful director she is about her experience. Because we were talking so much about her.
她读了高中、大学，所有这些，还有硕士学位。所以她当然会成功，因为她从第一天起就知道自己想做什么。我们甚至没怎么谈论她作为导演有多成功，也没谈论她的经验。因为我们一直在谈论她本人。
We were so into her life. She has so many layers that you're like, you're just like, yeah, I want to hear more about that. She's also just got a great spirit. You just want to like, I just found myself just listening to her, not wanting to cut her off as I've got a bad habit of doing. She's just, she doesn't keep a conversation going.
我们太沉浸在她的生活中了。她有很多层面，让你觉得，你就是想听更多关于她的事。她还有一种很棒的精神。你就是想，我发现自己只是在听她说话，不想打断她，尽管我有这个坏习惯。她就是，她不会让谈话冷场。
And she's just infectious. I really, I really like, and plus the fact, I mean, that what Max and she has done with the 29 year marriage, I think is like incredible. That's a really hard thing to do. Specifically in this business, we spend so much time away from one another.
而且她很有感染力。我真的，我真的，再加上马克斯和她维持了29年的婚姻，我觉得这太不可思议了。这是一件非常难做到的事情。特别是在这个行业，我们花太多时间彼此分离了。
I think that that can't be overlooked either. And they work together. What do you love about that? They work together. Well, what, the continuity of it all? The marriage, yeah. The marriage is that, that it's- Why is that important to you?
我觉得这一点也不容忽视。而且他们还一起工作。你喜欢这一点吗？他们一起工作。嗯，什么，这种连续性吗？婚姻，是的。婚姻就是，它是——为什么这对你很重要？
Oh God. Don't make me cry, Will. No, you tell me why it's fucking important to you. Because it's hard to do nowadays? Yeah. I don't know. I don't know. Don't tell, don't look at me.
哦天哪。别让我哭，威尔。不，你告诉我为什么这对你来说很重要。因为现在很难做到吗？是的。我不知道。我不知道。别告诉我，别看着我。
I never pulled it off. If I- No, it's just, the fact that they've been together for so long and that they work together as well, and it's just, they're fun to hang out with those two. Yeah, I love her. She's so great. Yeah.
我从来没做到过。如果我——不，只是，他们在一起这么久，而且还能一起工作，这事实本身，和他们在一起玩很有趣。是的，我爱她。她太棒了。是的。
All right. Boy, how do we work up buy- By Coastal, by Coastal. By Coastal, no. No, we can't, you can't workshop it. Wait, can you hear my thoughts right now? We could also change it up and not do buy anymore. Oh, you know what?
好吧。天哪，我们怎么构思“双海岸”——双海岸，双海岸。双海岸，不。不，我们不能，你不能现场构思。等等，你能听到我现在的想法吗？我们也可以换个方式，不再用“双”这个词了。哦，你知道吗？
That reminds me, there's a great place to visit if you ever get out past the Middle East called Dubai. Did you just said- Oh, for fuck's sake, holy. We almost made it. We were so close, we'd almost pull it off. Bae, the skin of our teeth. Oh, there you go, you saved it.
这让我想起，如果你去过中东以外的地方，有个叫迪拜的好地方。你刚才说了——哦，该死，天哪。我们差点就成功了。我们离成功那么近，差点就做到了。险之又险。哦，你救场了。
Woo! Bae, the skin of our teeth. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart.
呜！险之又险。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。
Smart. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
聪明。本集暂无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。